you know hello i know you're in a good
mood i'm not to be honest i'm going to
be totally honest with you up front
um because i think that's what this
podcast is honesty and uh i started
doing the podcast with my daughter
originally because i you know is a
quality time together
and we were
wasn't it you were we were locked in in
quarantine you can't tell if you're just
listening but she's looking at me
incredulously incredulously as you said
you're
i don't know where this is going okay
so uh i i like my time with you and and
uh just being here and meeting people
and doing whatever we're doing and uh i
like it's also entrepreneurial we we
talk about merch we're selling merch and
we want subscribers and we've been
getting growing with subscribers and
we've been selling merch and loomers
i'm gonna i'll just say it i don't know
how to put it any other
no
no i'm a little uh disappointed is i
don't know what the word is i'm upset
with you jackie
why okay this is what i don't understand
i know what you're talking about you're
talking about and we have it up well
first of all let me just say that jackie
i'm very proud of you you have uh we're
all on social media you have on social
media you have besides jacqueline
schultz you have um [ __ ] mom say
[ __ ] dad say
dads do [ __ ] dads do
and the pet one yeah
and then i just happened to be online
and i was scrolling and i was looking i
look at etsy
no you saw i posted my etsy shop that's
what you're talking about right yeah
so you went and looked at my etsy store
yeah
you have said the filthiest things as a
comic why are you met and even on this
podcast why i don't understand because i
feel like that's like you're selling
porn i'm not selling porn wait can we
bring up my store okay pretty dirty
gifts this is her store
okay
and then no i want to hear lou's opinion
this is my daughter this is my daughter
lou
this is my daughter the mother of two a
uh a college graduate a uh a teacher a
master's degree yeah and um
there's a uh this is what you paid for
dad
uh penis on a there's a penis on a on a
mug that you're selling it's a cute
penis isn't it cute i don't see it which
one is oh the chubby yeah
[Laughter]
you don't see that luke now i see it
says some people call me chubby and
there's a penis on a mug but it's cute
isn't it cute it's a penis on a mug and
you're my daughter and i don't want you
to be selling porn yeah i have to agree
with allie on this okay no i'm i'm being
serious i don't i'm not
born first of all this is the only one
that show me another one
um how about don't be a dildo
that's funny that one's funny don't be a
dildo and it's a a dill pickle and a and
a dough and a deer a female deer
ray a drop of golden sun
go go to i'll show you i'm i don't i
feel there's another one don't be a
richard it's another dick joke yeah
poopsicle
uh what's the one there's two shirt
no [ __ ] my shirt i need a break from
anyone who has come in or out of my
vagina
no that's not good i don't even want to
hear you say it let it out
i didn't write vagina i put a picture of
a kitty
no
why
caroline's saying yeah she likes it
caroline you're not my daughter if you
did that fine i hope you sell a lot of
them my i don't want my daughter to talk
about what goes in and out of her vagina
what are the other ones i just
um there's two waffle i have my hot
waffle i have it i didn't see that one
don't be a [ __ ] waffle what is a [ __ ]
waffle is that what i think it is like
like a waffle
it's like a waffle
if i may uh-huh yeah
okay uh i think that if you want to be
creative jackie and you're a very very
creative person wait wait wait didn't
what's the 1595 that one what they're
all all the mugs are
go down a little bit that one cupcake
[ __ ] cake
don't be a [ __ ] cake
jackie or i'm not a paleontologist but i
know a contosaurus when i see one
no okay so
if you if you want to be creative you
you are very creative yeah if you have
limitations to your creativity if you
put your creativity in a smaller focused
area no that's the problem it is in a
small focused area i want her to get out
of that area
i don't want her selling things with the
c word i don't want you selling things
with the t word i don't want you not
look they're not separate words it's one
word so i created my own word no i don't
want to you know what biscuit dick
biscuit
shut up
shut up
i'm going to call your mom i'm going to
i actually have a legitimate question
though because someone asked me this
other day
someone asked me are you not scared
because your kids go to school like you
have kids what if they see this i don't
think this is a bad thing right if like
no no not a bad thing
no
no it is a bad thing as a grandparent
yeah lou's saying it's a bad thing
i would like to know in the comments no
when this goes up no comments nothing
i'm
instead of writing 37 years old i can't
ground you i wish there was some way to
punish you i want
instead of going in the comments now get
out turn off her mic instead of just
going all the comments turn off her mic
turn off her mic turn off her mic
see it's off no
no no no no no and your mic doesn't go
back on until you close your etsy close
your etsy that sounds terrible
everything i'm saying sounds terrible
[Music]
you